bootleg cat podcasts RR Tommy in the
building representing east side of
Detroit is here man yeah uh uh how long
you been rapping bro
uh my whole life for real for real but
professionally about a year first so
you're pretty new to like getting money
off the rap game yeah yeah all right
well look man east side of Detroit I
always hear when we talk about the East
Side versus the West Side everybody
always says the West side's like a
little more flyer the east side is a
little more grimy is that fair I mean
look at me I must say You're Gonna Fly
you know what's up uh west side though
you feel me no I think it's dope too
because like everybody's it feels like
working together now I want some [__]
like doing together you know all right
let's get right to it man come on
some [__] like that
yeah all that hating that you did yeah
backfire rolly color sapphire you put
out like a campfire I'm on the road 100
P's in a Pathfinder with gotta run flat
tires Bulletproof the glass I'm in that
drop top crawling out a black spider
young isn't a black Striker watching for
the back parties I came for nothing so I
stacked the very last dollar new season
last product that's that's why they mad
about it
yeah
or some [__] like that
betray what's the deal
yeah yeah that paid my first look like a
gun put my [__] saying the rock ace
of spades on the rock all these diamonds
on me rock you can see me down the block
I'm on the road with a box my stomach
tied in a knot say you real no you're
not tell them meet me at the top the
[__] worry about the Ops I'm only
worried about the cops got the game from
my pots Steph Curry with the shot sex
fifth I like the shot forever real I
can't stop it [__] balling in New York
like I'm with the Knicks Roger Vinci
imma pick imma get it if it prick Mash
song like I'm ripped I've been real
since legit all the mark Carter your
braces layered up my wrist yeah
[Music]
hey I know you just watched a new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off your checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week